what's up beautiful babies welcome to
the episode of get close
i'm a knowing geo and i'm really cool
you are pretty cool
when i do these [ __ ] intros i annoy
the [ __ ] out of myself you know that i
think they're cute i think sometimes i
go a little too far and then as i'm
doing it like this [ __ ]
i'm like man [ __ ] shut up i think
they're cute i think i'm my i'm my best
friend and also my worst enemy
so the the best friend is like
like stick to it because you don't
really you commit to what you commit you
don't go like what up gig
whatever hey what's up bart you know
it's not it's like you don't you don't
shut yourself off yeah
i'm like [ __ ] it i already made a right
turn into [ __ ] stupid ass annoying
town might as well just get out of this
lane close it up nicely and just keep it
moving you know
it's like i fall on my face and instead
of getting up in or like sitting down
there and going like i'm so embarrassed
and then looking around the room to see
like who caught that yeah you might as
well run run into that and then stick
your head in the toilet no no no i'll
fall and i'll just [ __ ] laugh it off
and just keep it moving baby
um as we were getting ready right now i
was looking at your [ __ ] toenails and
this is something about you that i just
don't understand because i can't let
this happen
you let your toenails get so [ __ ]
long that it gives me anxiety okay
you know why why
because like
so like i just imagine your toenails
getting caught on something
bending backwards and then breaking off
exactly
how do you let them grow along i can't
let mine
grow at all i [ __ ] hate
maintenance you know that
yeah you don't say no no i'm not even
talking about this kind of [ __ ] like my
ideal world
um as i'm working
my chair
would be a toilet
right because i i always get in the zone
and then when i get in the zone i get
some sick ass [ __ ] ideas only to be
interrupted by [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] or p p p
and i'm like [ __ ] i gotta [ __ ] get up
and lose momentum and i [ __ ] hate
haircuts so if there was like a machine
that i could just sit there and as i'm
working the machine comes and goes did
you like [ __ ] laser cut my hair i
could just [ __ ] and piss and then my
toenail like i have a if the keyboard
you stick off 10 fingers in and it's
like nibbling at your nails while you're
typing
i it sounds like you've thought about
this [ __ ] before a lot
because these are all inventions
these are all the inventions that i
cannot come up come up with off the dome
so it's a [ __ ] keyboard that as
you're typing it's shaving your nails
down yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] rough because i have ocd right
so uh when you have ocd
you um
you every time i talk to you the ocd
conversation changes by the way why yeah
because you're like i think i have ocd
to now it's more like uh i have slight
ocd to literally today now you're saying
you have it well i got diagnosed when i
was a kid how old
uh 12 13. who the [ __ ] did i marry and
how was that diagnosed like well how did
that okay how did we lead up to you even
needing a diagnosis
so um as you know i'm uh pretty stellar
in school when it comes to jumping
around
when it comes to mischievousness yeah
right so when i was uh
in junior high
like 12 13 um
like when i tried i would get like the
top scorer in the class
for almost all my classes
and if i didn't give a [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] saying you're too goddamn smart
so you get bored
maybe because i can't [ __ ] relate or
maybe i'm stupid or
i've never been the top of the class
ever what if you really tried you tried
really hard i don't even know what
that's like
oh really yeah i don't even know if i've
ever really tried because i think
halfway through my best friend comes in
it's like take it easy you've done
enough and i'm like you're right [ __ ]
that's obviously a mexican best friend
that holds you back in life so none of
my best friends inside are mexican so
they're all like
what the [ __ ] why did you have to look
up you [ __ ] loser i'm the envision
i got eugene i got andy i got aaron you
know eugene's the korean one huh yeah
yeah okay go and he's the one that
drives me because he's full of revenge
and um
when when i'm like in those classes
i don't know why maybe because school
was too easy so i needed to have my own
internal competition
so i remember um
and so like i think it started some of
this revenge stuff started i think um
i think this this [ __ ] like hate
studying i think started like even back
in fourth grade what the [ __ ] is hate
studying like hate [ __ ] yeah you
don't hate [ __ ] but you hate study
it's the same [ __ ] makes me feel horny
but when i was in fourth it must be an
asian thing it might be
i've never heard that when i was in
fourth grade
in mrs anderson's class um i think they
wanted to see where everyone's math
level was at so if you kind of need a
little bit of help you'll be in math
team b if you're like kind of ahead of
the curve you'll be math team a and then
that way when it came down to math
she'll break it down into two classes
even though there's only like 30
something students
so we got this worksheet [ __ ] ton of
students yeah so we got these worksheets
right and then they're old school
remember back when we went to school
like it was
almost still like screen projector days
no powerpoint so all the worksheets are
from like 70s or whatever right so
they're like half xerox they probably
use the same master copy over and over
they lost that so now they use a faint a
more faint one to copy so a lot of the
math problems were like just i thought
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] lazy by the way
what was it i was like why don't these
teachers just [ __ ] redo it like why
do they let this [ __ ] get xerox to the
point where she can't even make it or he
can't make it out yeah yeah but this is
where it all starts okay anyway so
there'll be this work event yeah there's
this worksheet to have like 50 problems
on there right
and it's one number one number one
number on top of one number as you get
to the bottom there might be like two
numbers one number
to the bottom two numbers two numbers
right like double digit double digit
stacked across the the very iconic
mathematics line that goes to the bottom
right but it's faintly printed
so when we get these sheets because
we're in fourth grade i'm nine years old
i look at them and i'm like i can't read
half of this [ __ ] so i'm gonna assume
they're all multiplication
this has got to be because addition like
in nine when you're nine doing double
digit addition yeah that's that's like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] right so i was like bam
ready go
boom done i was the first one done
because i always have these internal i
guess i guess the the hate study and
start even before that but i just always
wanted to beat everyone i turn it into
miss anderson she starts going like this
what up
wrong what a [ __ ] all wrong [ __ ] you
miss anderson and then i started looking
and it would be like three over four
with the line and then i put twelve
right and then wrong wrong wrong
supposed to be [ __ ] seven and yeah
and i was like looking at their answer
key and i'm like
i'm like mrs anderson
i'm like she's like you got all of them
wrong
is she that's [ __ ] stupid she didn't
go yeah she didn't go oh
barton
you silly goose wasn't for you you're so
smart i it doesn't matter you know that
it's [ __ ] multiplication you [ __ ]
dumb ass adult so as you know the
caliber of teachers are swear what what
what school district are we talk about
well cereal is a really good school oh
so she's part of that yeah and she
always wore nice skirts too but she
could be shorter were they long uh they
could be shorter why the [ __ ] they could
be shorter yeah why the [ __ ] are you
looking at her skirts dude you knew we
were going to get married why the [ __ ]
would you do that i'm four feet tall
that's all i saw i just saw skirt and
panty
especially when she bent over oh
you're so nasty
so anyways i was like oh miss anderson
um i did multiplication so that's why i
wrote 12 and she was like
so she redid the whole thing and now i
got all of them right so while the rest
of the class was doing addition i did
multiplication still sitting there doing
it and i was the first one and second
place didn't even come close second
place probably finished like 10 minutes
after me dude i would have been the last
person to finish
i suck at taking tests i always doubt
myself
it could be like how do you okay three
times four what is the doubtfulness
there um well okay that's like really
easy right but then like let's say it
was like uh addition right like say
right now you give me a two plus two
okay seven plus eight what is that well
tell me seven plus eight fifteen five so
that what pretty good well that's faster
than i thought i was gonna be
[ __ ] you
um what was i saying no it's just when
it's too easy i'm like no because i i
always think i'm a dumb ass like i
always think i'm a [ __ ] idiot so then
when it's too easy right like uh i don't
know if the lady buys four eggs she
drops two on the floor
how many does she have left i'm like
well does she's only enough two and i'm
like but wait
is this like a trick question like why
is it so easy wait what like now i gotta
start look like i started doing
unnecessary work i'm like uh does
something about what she was wearing
like did they say that like wait why did
they have to point out that she had a
polka dotted dress oh [ __ ] is that
telling me something and then i read
into it
i know i'm just saying in general when
it comes to taking tests i see just
generally
i always overthink it to the point where
i think myself out of the correct uh
answer so what would you put she has
four eggs she drops two what would you
put okay well that's just a bad example
right zero cause she bought she got so
pissed so she slammed all of them on the
ground
maybe maybe i would do that but remember
when we had to take our driving test all
over again um i missed a bunch of like
the [ __ ]
yeah they're like it's the easiest and i
was just like how did it how the [ __ ]
did i miss that and you're like no they
really meant like
you know what are you supposed to do
when you see a red light and i'm like no
way no way they're handing it blows my
mind because it'll literally be a
question that is literally like this
someone cuts you off what is the
appropriate action to take and it goes a
speed up and flip them off
b
honk at them until you get their
attention
three maintain a gap and give them some
safety distance
there's no there's always one that's in
the middle no it's pull over and let
them pass or some [ __ ] like speed up
and
pull over and throw down yeah there's
that middle one and i always pick that
middle one and i'm like come on dude i'm
like it can't be that [ __ ] stupid but
then i'm that stupid that i still get it
wrong well the the the when it comes to
the driving test i think the ones that
are tricky are like the distance or
numbers based one
because then then that i'm kind of like
i don't know so like uh if like
like what how how how far away should
you start slowing down from the stop
sign or something it's like 100 feet 200
feet 300 feet oh yeah that one is right
that's not really like common sensical
that's just more do you know what the
actual number is yeah because you're
looking smart so those ones i'm like
whatever but all the other ones like
like 40 out of the 50 problems they're
usually common sense based they are but
i just make it so hard for myself
because i'm like it can't be this easy
someone's trying to pull it fast on me
oh boy anyway so okay so that's nine
you're nine years old fourth grade that
was the first time you realized what
that you're smart and you get bored and
how did we lead to the ocd that uh jump
started
my because it's not the hate math
because you said you had that i guess i
had probably a little bit of hate math
um but it really i think ignited the the
hate [ __ ] studying because i was just
like how
dare me like you or how dare you you
saw me as such low intelligence that you
saw three over four and then two over
six and all these other numbers that you
could clearly just like
glance across and you knew i did
multiplication and you still marked them
all wrong only for a nine year old to
correct a 45 year old lady
oh looking up her skirt you're looking
up [ __ ] 45 year old [ __ ] you nasty
yeah because two [ __ ]
lips times one butthole is still two
you're disgusting yeah so i was like
damn so i think since then i just had
like this like
maybe like chip on my shoulder
that how could someone assume i was that
stupid and that's the pivotal that's
like the the memory that stuck with you
that moment yeah and i think from that
point on
almost like i have the same almost like
a track record i take a new class
or uh take a new subject or whatever the
first test
usually like a hundred percent
and um
after that
f's f f like if i feel like i could own
this class i would try my hardest the
first one
and not even try my hardest i would take
chinese school into the [ __ ] so
you know what i was uh in chinese school
like it's not
like you can get a plus plus plus plus
right a plus is already 100 so how do
you get a plus plus because they also uh
grade you on calligraphy like um
composition of the chinese word so you
can write like let's say the answer is
that is crazy yeah so like they're like
you [ __ ] nailed it but then the other
students would be like but i my work is
neater yeah then now you get a plus plus
why do you think asian kids got the best
penmanship that's [ __ ] crazy yeah so
like um like you can write maybe the
answer to a question is like go go right
like it's dog and you write go and if
you write it all sloppy but the teacher
can still read it that'll be 100
but at the end of the test if the other
person wrote it perfectly i [ __ ] hate
that and perfectly in the square then
they'll get it right so sometimes they
just want they can't wait to make you a
teacher's pet [ __ ] that honestly
teachers pets do really good in asia no
[ __ ] like crazy yeah they're probably
the plus plus plus plus plus [ __ ] those
kids yeah but some uh i'm a hater some
[ __ ] classes
i owned like i [ __ ] like grabbed my
teacher's skull and you [ __ ] [ __ ]
them so hard that i'll finish the test
[ __ ] fast right
i look around and i'm like what the [ __ ]
duff is still on page one i'm already
finished with all five pages i'll
literally go back and chinese school it
so like you know that the type of [ __ ]
where you go where you match
match what
answered a question
oh uh-huh you make the lines straighter
yeah i just [ __ ] i'm like i got so
much time i'll erase all of them and
then i'll get like a ruler and i'm like
okay that's a perfect line for you
teacher because it's so [ __ ] boring
and then another one like let's say
here's a blank right and like let's say
i wrote the answer here i'll erase it
and center the word over the line i was
just like oh [ __ ] so i was like we were
so opposite as i was taking a test let's
see i'm looking at you
what's the polka dot dress with anything
that and outside be like oh [ __ ] they're
already turning the page [ __ ]
i had so much time
i'll probably
take the side of the test
draw the lady with the polka dot test
with the polka dot dress dropping the
egg so you can flip it and watch the
animation happen probably and i'm still
[ __ ] on page one yeah i'm like dude
are you [ __ ] kidding me this is
[ __ ] easy as [ __ ]
yeah is this coming from your mom's ass
beatings
you're like so snappy
or is it like a combination of like
you're already pretty smart plus your
mom had you in advance like it's just
like the perfect storm
i think it's probably a perfect storm
because kind of like you
um when my mom had me she was eating
like all the perfect things that she was
supposed to eat so she's like oh first
trimester you got to eat like dates or
some [ __ ] you know second trimester like
oh the brain is developing so let's get
some fish oils or whatever her chinese
way of doing things yeah so i think she
was really trying to make sure like she
had like the healthiest baby so she did
that that's hilarious because you came
out so [ __ ]
well
i was also vegetarian for like the first
like 12 years of my life yeah but you're
also flat-footed you have asthma your
eyes are fogged
thank you you have bloody noses all the
goddamn time
would have been
imagine what it would have been if she
didn't do eat all that [ __ ] or you would
have probably been the other way if she
would have at least had some [ __ ]
protein intake yeah and then yeah so she
um
she did what i'm called you look so sad
my mom tried her best hey she did good
with your brain because you have a
big-ass cranium so it's all good i know
i think i have the head of someone
that's supposed to be like 62 or
something you [ __ ] it looks like it
yeah but i'm happy you have a thick neck
everything else is small
um so yeah she did all that and then she
taught me how to do addition when i was
in
preschool
already like double over like 35 plus 43
so if you're doing that [ __ ] at like
three or four years old you know um no
wonder when i was nine taking a test out
like there's no way that we're doing
audition i was doing this before i even
started kindergarten come on
and then yeah and then so like she would
drive to preschool and then she would
really want me to get good at math
because she was good at math so she
should be like 14 plus 47 too slow boom
just whack me in the face 31 plus 33 too
slow boom whack me in the face i'm just
getting my ass be on the way to [ __ ]
this preschool instead of 33 you
should've got yours because that's
pretty [ __ ] easy really even has it
do you
can't do it fair yeah no tych is a
different bird
boy he's a one two three four five five
mama
[Laughter]
yeah so like but he's a happy dude yeah
so i think because of that i was like
really fast yeah and then um
yeah and then she taught me
multiplication like this is the fun this
type of fun [ __ ] that we would have like
in first grade
like people would go and play basketball
their dad my mom's making me memorize
like multiplication tables when i was
six
so i think i already knew all that [ __ ]
so so [ __ ] advanced uh that the rest
of the school became so [ __ ] easy
so that um uh and she didn't know [ __ ]
about the la schools like district or
just not even alley but just the u.s
school right like she didn't know
that the curriculum was so behind
compared to like whatever is going on in
asia
or was she aware
um or she probably just assumed right
that like all schools run the exact same
way
i think what she didn't assume or she
didn't realize is that um
her pre-teaching me was gonna [ __ ] me
over
oh yeah because
um like it's not because cerritos like
the the school district there is
actually pretty good
and they teach age-appropriate stuff
you know
so it wasn't that the school was behind
i was just ahead and then because i was
so ahead i was so [ __ ] bored got it
okay so at what point are you like this
[ __ ] got ocd so when i was so i
think once i started having that hate
studying thing then i'm gonna start
owning every [ __ ] teacher
um
then like as the test became easier and
easier and i got better at better and
better at that like that's when i think
like my ocd tendencies uh
was um
it started to come out more like i
already had like weird ocd i have to
close the door a certain way how old are
we talking
um
as soon as i had responsibilities maybe
like six or seven like if my mom were
like hey lock the door it had to be like
top down i couldn't like do it whatever
if i and if i started at the bottom like
oh [ __ ] so i unlock the bottom so you
know if you have to lock the top and the
bottom if someone locks the bottom they
go oh i just lock the top no i had to
unlock the bottom start from the top and
go down i like these little weird quirks
what else that i didn't even know what
the label was so i just lived with it
you know it wasn't like oh i have ocd
it's just like oh that's weird i have to
do this
oh yeah it even felt weird to you yeah
because i would because to me it's not
logical i'm like if you need to lock two
locks and i locked one of them then i
just locked the other one why i don't
have to unlock the other one to lock it
so you would fight yourself you'd be
like what the [ __ ] am i doing what's
this feeling this is a weird feeling
and then that's the obsess uh obsessive
part you know so i'm like what's this
weird feeling that i gotta like i gotta
like go do it for some reason yeah or if
i uh like i have to pee before i go to
sleep i have to pee before i eat
and then it'll be like during recess i
just peed so now it's lunch time i know
i don't have any pee but why do i have
to go to the bathroom and still try to
force a drop out like it's so weird okay
so we're talking about six now moving on
up moving up to junior high and then so
in junior high uh when i started getting
into hella trouble
um that's when my assistant principal
shout out to mr tarple he's super
[ __ ] cool
um he was the one that brought in the
the district psychologist
to see what was going on with me because
he was like because i think a lot of
teachers they didn't really have like
faith in me so they just kind of ruled
me out parts of a bad kid he just like
gets into trouble and all that [ __ ] how
are people so dumb
it's never just because a person's bad
yeah
[ __ ] teachers man if you're a [ __ ]
teacher get your [ __ ] straight yeah but
shout out to mr tarpley because mr
tarpley was the one that was like you
know what like bart's actually really
smart i need to figure out what's going
on because it's really cool i don't
think it's just him being in trouble
because he would would literally crush a
test and then
um
and then he [ __ ] up you know yeah i'm
like seeing all these pictures of you
when you were a kid with your [ __ ]
thick-ass
wrong glasses and your like [ __ ]
stereotypical asian haircut and just
looking all dorky and [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ]
i [ __ ] hate you
why do you hate me
because you're causing all this trouble
and like i wasn't a troublemaking kid
you know and i'm like i [ __ ] hate
that guy i'm trying to [ __ ] figure
out what the [ __ ] polka dotted [ __ ]
did
like why is his test so [ __ ] hard how
does he finish though yeah and he looks
so [ __ ] geeky he has no goddamn steez
[ __ ] loser
yeah so i would uh
i would um yeah and so the teacher that
the the district psychologist
ended up saying i had like 80 adhd and
have a slight ocd how do they figure
that [ __ ] out you don't know how you do
tests oh and at the same time they ran
an iq test they want to see if i was
stupid or not
but they know you're not stupid well
they don't know because
that's like a 1.0 gpa i see so i think
that's when i first you had like
learning disabilities yeah so uh
at and that's when they found out like
my iq was actually really high as a
junior high kid i think i scored like
i think 135 or 145 out of
well if you're like i think anything
over 160 or 170 you're like a genius or
something but i was so you're not a
genius but you're pretty 12.
what does that mean so imagine what it
is now it could be i don't know i don't
even i don't even know enough about the
world
to
to to fully execute that exam yet i see
you know what i mean like if you ask me
what a like uh what's a period i don't
even know what a period is
you know what i mean yeah yeah or like
do you know what how to vote i'm like i
don't even understand how democracy like
the world's con like the amount of cons
like with my 12 years of concepts i was
able to like do that well on an adult
exam fine i'm just trying to talk [ __ ]
but that is pretty [ __ ] smart good
for you and the iq test yeah was [ __ ]
up my alley like crazy i was like can
all [ __ ] tests be like this [ __ ]
sick are you serious yeah so they'll be
like a um some of them are kind of like
brain teasers where like oh no i'm so
[ __ ] i don't know it's very objective
though so one of them would be like you
so whatever one of them would be like a
diagram right yeah like here's a diagram
and here's all these random shapes
make these shapes look like that and
then boom kitchen timer
so the minute i saw that timer i was
like oh
because i was like finally a challenge
you know so it should be like boom it'll
be like set to like i don't know 60
seconds or something did you roll your
eyes before you started
and then did it because
i think i was about to i was probably
like
okay i already and then i saw the timer
i was like
and then
started doing it i loved it
i [ __ ] love that stuff damn yeah yeah
that ain't my [ __ ] at all i'm a [ __ ]
idiot
they're they're kind of fun they're some
of them are kind of like uh like
festival games you know the kind where
like like here's here's like 20 objects
under a blanket memorize as many as you
can
and then
and they cover it yeah i [ __ ] myself
over with those two and you started
listing them out i'm like oh easy bam
bam bam and i'm like but was it wait
that was way too easy stop okay let's
think about it and then i started
questioning myself and then i [ __ ]
myself i'm telling you i [ __ ]
self-sabotage like a [ __ ] that's
kenny i'm stupid no you are all right
thank you okay so then um
so that's when i first officially got
diagnosed with it got it with add adhd
ocd and uh and then i also found out my
mom had low iq
okay well my mom's like you can't just
[ __ ] say she was like she's like 135.
i'm like what's yours mom she's like i
think i got 90.
i'm like
damn what the [ __ ]
i'm like
i think you're done
really what's considered i didn't say
that by citing my brain of course but
what would uh what's considered dumb i
think like
80 or 90 i think that range is like
average you mean yeah it's average okay
so average for you is dumb
well compared to like the standard mom's
trying to hold me to i see like every
time my mom was whooping my ass my
grandma was like what do you want bart
to be the president or something so it's
like my mom was holding up to this
extremely high standard starting she
couldn't even live up to it yeah and she
has a [ __ ] 80 iq come on dude i love
how it dropped 10 points good for you
yeah give it to her
come on are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah
so she got how many points [ __ ] 75
yeah [ __ ] dumbass yeah um okay so
then how do we tie that back to you
[ __ ] having claws dude okay good i'm
glad that we're telling this christopher
nolan movie that goes forwards and
backwards and forwards and backwards
so
um because i have ocd
it's really hard from like once i am
dialed in on a task or initiative
it's really hard to pull me off of it
because and and because i have adhd
because if you pull me off of it i don't
give a [ __ ] about it anymore
oh [ __ ] and so because i know that about
myself so they're almost like two like
superpowers that pull you away from
success
because i know that about myself um
i try to keep myself in the cockpit
you know what i mean fair so for example
what's something that's [ __ ]
important that's going on right
now what do you mean like right now
we're podcasting
here here's a simple example this is
[ __ ] crazy but it's not like this
don't [ __ ] test me bro i [ __ ] told
you my anxiety god damn it let's say
um
was that the right answer at least no
[ __ ] let's see let's say i'm supposed to
go pick up taika from school
okay
and then i go i hear the little voice in
my head your voice
you didn't even cut your [ __ ] nails
i'm like oh [ __ ] you know what you're
right why did i say it so nice okay okay
so i'll pull over
i cut my nails
then i don't give a [ __ ] about taika
i'm like chilling i'm in a different
mindset now
what do you mean like you just you
forget that he even exists the urgency
to pick him up is not even there so now
what happens i'll go home
and then you go home and you're like oh
[ __ ] i gotta pick him up dad text you
can you go pick up taco i had to cut my
nails
that's never happened though like that's
not even something you do that's why my
nails are this long
but you don't have like designated
grooming time like when you're taking a
shower out here i hear you clip it why
not do it every [ __ ] week well when
i'm in the shower and i'm doing it i'm
already like three three [ __ ] weeks
past due
yeah no it's gnarly man i see it and i'm
like
holy [ __ ] i can just already see it chip
like taiko right now because like he's a
little ass boy he doesn't understand so
like when i do go cut his nose when he
does jiu jitsu i have to keep him really
groomed because he can't be [ __ ]
calling people including his feet when i
look at his feet it looks like someone
just like was like randomly biting his
toenails because they're all chipped and
cracked because he plays so hard and
he's holding on to [ __ ] and i'm like as
a kid fine i get it sometimes there's
like a little bit of blood oh man that's
making me cringe like crazy
and then i see yours and i'm like oh and
then you put [ __ ] your socks over it
and i and then you put shoes and i
imagine and then i imagine your [ __ ]
claws scraping the inside of the [ __ ]
sh the tube the toe box
and i'm like ah
you know what else drives me [ __ ]
crazy and i didn't realize i don't know
where this comes from what um and i
remember the [ __ ] perfect
i have the memory of when i saw it that
made me feel so uncomfortable inside
what and i still feel it till this day
especially when i get a pedicure okay
you know your little pinky toe yeah when
that is like ah okay so when you put
that like if i put this over or like i
move it in like outside of what it needs
to be so when people are wearing sandals
and their pinky toes sticking out that
[ __ ] drives me crazy or if they're
wearing like lacy sandals [ __ ] you got
ocd
maybe
but you know when they're wearing like
like uh not lazy but like
like different like tiritas you know
what i mean like little [ __ ] the darita
what the [ __ ] is that spanish like a
tita like a like a little strap like
little straps okay um and they're
wearing like sandals and then their
little [ __ ] toe sticks out of one of
those
spaces yeah i'm like [ __ ] put your
[ __ ] toe back in the [ __ ] thing
with all your other toes
i think that's how our toes are supposed
to operate
i think our toes are supposed to spread
and that's fine it's spread i don't mind
the spreading but it's like when it
moves so when like i'm getting my
pedicure done yeah and then she like
these she pushes these down and this one
up i'm like oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god please stop please stop
i think you got ocd that that's the only
weird [ __ ] i do that have
what all right
what did you just say i'm still thinking
about it so i remember i was in like
third grade
in the [ __ ] um i was in the sandbox
after school because my mom was a
teacher so i always had to stay after
school and like just [ __ ] off for like a
few hours while she got her work done
so i was in the sandbox and then one of
the students uh one of yeah one of the
students mom came and she was wearing
sandals and her [ __ ] pinky toe was
sticking out of this sandal just
scraping the floor not scraping the
floor but it's just sticking out so it's
like because you know some people's toes
like are straight and sometimes like
they walk but it still sticks up like
your mom's west side toes oh come on
she's got arthritis in her feet oh well
your mom is [ __ ] repping hearted
though yes she is okay so like hers was
sticking out and i remember looking at
that and i could just i felt like i was
gonna throw up like not because it was
disgusting but it just made me feel so
uncomfortable yeah i couldn't do it
in the sandbox and i was like [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] and i just kept looking at it it
was just made me feel like you keep
looking at it for it stop looking at it
there you know when you have like the
[ __ ] nasty [ __ ] just throw some sand
on it
i boy i'm not gonna get in trouble you
[ __ ] troublemaker you see i'm so glad
we went girl together
[ __ ] it basically it feels so
yucky inside
you can't relate huh nah
[ __ ]
can we just change the subject i think
the thing that makes me feel weird and
yucky have you ever seen people some
people got moles that look like
mushrooms
moles that look like mushrooms what does
that mean like
i see it on like this is the one teacher
that we had on her neck
it would grow like
my dad had it my sister has it i think
it's prone in my family yeah it's just a
it's a your dad got mushrooms
yeah yeah and you get them you get them
actually cut off oh god yeah they can
like do it with like a the old-school
way is like you can do it with like a
thread and just let the circulation and
then it just falls off on its own um or
you can get it like freeze-dried and
then it falls off they could surgically
connect
with no mushrooms
who me yeah no but it's in my family but
i don't have no mushrooms in front of me
that's disgusting i forgot what it's
called
but my family has it like my dad has it
my sister has it no i don't want to be
seeing that [ __ ] mushrooms even had
one on his eyelid oh he had a mushroom
on the island
so i think for me it's just it's i'm
used to seeing it because when i saw
that i was like why don't people when
they're cutting their nails
off cause it's skin it still hurts
oh
that's
i love where this conversation goes
yeah for me i think because i have ocd
that's why my normal maintenance
i mean ocd and adhd that's what my
normal maintenance sucks like this truck
right now
is probably the first truck
that i have never uh gone over miles
before i got my oil change
almost every other car
it's like if i was supposed to get an
oil change at like 5 000 miles
i end up getting like 6 000 or 7 000
like every single because just all my
personal maintenance stuff yeah you suck
like those things they never come at a
good time right so you're always in the
zone of something and then so i'm like
okay i'm finally motivated to go do this
and crush it at this
am i really gonna let go of this to cut
my nails for 15 minutes and then i don't
give a [ __ ] anymore
interesting i guess that makes sense
yeah yeah i guess that makes sense and i
can see the urgency why you maintain
this truck so much is because you're
literally driving like [ __ ] 400 miles
every two weeks i need it to operate and
i've because of my ocd i like like i
think the first oil change that was
required was that five thousand
i just got to change like three thousand
i was like i'll [ __ ] it because i know
if i don't get it now it's gonna be
[ __ ] nine thousand you know yeah yeah
yeah so i might as well just do it
[ __ ] early i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
yeah and i've been testing this new
thing
um
because i realize it's not even on you
because before i thought you were trying
to control me but then it was just in my
own brain of uh when have i ever tried
to control you it's just me it's me
though it's completely me i'm not a
controlling person well it's just for me
i think it's like um
probably the ocd in my own head yeah
right where
like
i think before it would be like let's
say if i'm away from the family or
something for like too much work and
i'll be like oh don't you want to spend
time with us this weekend and then oh
that's true and so i think that will
haunt me to the point where i'm like oh
[ __ ] if i get oil change i'm away from
the family oh if i cut my nails i'm away
from the family so everything else i
just don't even like touch it you know
yeah i literally call you an absent
father because it's so funny i know but
now i know they're joking around i don't
know you're joking around before when i
called you an absent father yeah you're
not an absent father you're a highly
involved father what are you talking
about
you're a [ __ ] comedian dude i know
but i got ocd and adhd you gotta feel
sorry for me i don't feel [ __ ] sorry
for you i feel sorry for that neck
looking around that [ __ ] fat ass head
all day i know so just i'm getting
better which is good at 38 this year i'm
getting better i'm trying to like uh
understand my maintenance stuff is okay
i'm not gonna drop the ball in other
things i'm really trying to like stick
to it
yeah i'm starting to get the hang of
being a human being
and we would have so many fights of like
you being like i'm on top of my [ __ ] all
the time well the important [ __ ]
the important [ __ ] like [ __ ] nails
that's not even important this is [ __ ]
you know you we shouldn't even be
cutting these
if we crawled around on our hands and
knees the right way we would be filing
it down on the ground all day long like
dogs don't cut their [ __ ] nails don't
need to they do cut their [ __ ] nose
indoor [ __ ]
a true [ __ ] dog like a true dog yeah
yeah they have them so little that's
[ __ ] playing around yeah like tyson
we cut his nails zero times i cut his
nails all the time tyson yeah or
meatloaf tyson
no you never cut ty's i couldn't cut his
nails you know why because he had those
black talons and i was always so scared
i was gonna cut you don't need to come
it was the other the other dogs that we
started having when we have these
[ __ ] german shepherds that live on
wood floor it's like of course it was
carpeted but then our old dog
um duffel was a true dog yeah he was a
pretty good it was a true one i can't
wait to get dogs yeah i want a dog so
bad i was trying to talk i was trying to
think of all the [ __ ] that makes me like
makes my skin crawl and you remember
when these [ __ ] kids used to [ __ ]
flip their eyelids inside out
ah
do you remember i thought they were
[ __ ] uh
detarted
well anyway do you remember that yeah
yeah oh and that [ __ ] would drive me
crazy a lot of that elementary school
[ __ ] i just couldn't relate yeah like
people will do things i think like the
armpit farting right
when i first discovered i thought it was
hilarious and then fool's still doing in
the fifth grade
i'm like
are you serious
a lot of that [ __ ] like the [ __ ] the
ah don't do it or when people are like
can you switch their tongue
does it make like a w
so you couldn't do it i can do it can
you do a taco
you can't do a taco
i used it wait are you [ __ ] with me
yeah i can't do it oh yeah
what
i can't do it that makes sense now why
that makes sense
do what i just showed you
do what what do you want to do yeah no
we need the taco dude we need the taco
why do you need a taco you know why i
need the taco you don't even have a
penis
because it wraps the bottom of it
perfectly no you need the bowl for the
penis dude though
no that you close it up if you close the
hole where's the penis going to go right
there that's that mouth [ __ ] that's not
mouthpiece everyone talks about
he's so stupid i can't believe you can't
do a taco who the [ __ ] did i marry an
ocd non [ __ ] tongue taco guy i got
the
the [ __ ] cut the
the clitch ouster
look at that that's so slow all right
well everyone out there please feel
sorry for me because bart's click
[ __ ] licking game is soft
yeah you gotta practice more okay and
everyone decided to [ __ ] cut their
lawn right now at this very moment all
right fair um so okay fine i understand
a little bit better why
the nails are like that but yeah it's
just one of those things that like at
least before this conversation i'm just
like i can't i can't do it i can't do it
like it's just driving me crazy that's
why i've also been having eczema on my
balls too like aside from me
taking like or the dermatologist such a
[ __ ] amazing segway by because like
the dermatologist right they they
they needed like a month in advance so i
did schedule it but even just stuff like
that like little personal maintenance
it's so hard for me because once i'm in
personal maintenance mode
then
it goes like
pulls me off this then i'm like well i
might as well get the whole [ __ ] body
maintained i might as well order a
[ __ ] brazilian wax or facials and do
all that when have you ever done that to
prove what you're just saying correct
cause i always as soon as i come over
here i go get back over there yeah but
how do you know that that's what you're
gonna do because i can feel it all i
could feel it on the inside you've never
in the [ __ ] 13 15 20 plus years that
we've known each other because i [ __ ]
slapped myself back into place you've
never once done it you know because i
slapped myself back into place sometimes
like i say i'm going and i go i slap i
go right back there i don't believe it i
don't
know
like i don't believe you'll let the
[ __ ] rains go like that
no it's not my reigns it's my ocd adhd
right so like [ __ ] i'm focused i'm
locked in and as soon as i go oh i got
all this weird [ __ ] my ocd's taking over
and then as soon as the adhd breaks
loose boom i don't give a [ __ ] about
this
sayonara i'ma [ __ ] go over here and
i'm gonna [ __ ] do all this crazy [ __ ]
and then i'll come back like a month
later and guess what all my businesses
are destroyed
i kind of want to see that not the
business is destroyed obviously but i do
want to see you let go and give
in no you don't want to see it you've
never even seen it i've seen it in small
cases and other things like
like um when i got kicked out of school
in third grade you know
that doesn't tell me anything what does
that mean
how do i know you let go what did you
let go of and why did you like what so
picture i think the the picture adhd and
ocd this combination
picture it like a magnet
okay it's one of those where if it's
stuck on tight it's a superpower it
works really good
the minute it
breaks free it's [ __ ] free to go
anywhere else
and it can go into something that's also
productive
or it can go into something that's
unproductive and i'll go just as wonk
what about that one that one didn't move
this is already gone that one floated
away where does it go nowhere that that
that's the mating the receiving and that
thing's gone so which one is that adhd
or ocd no adhd and ocd is in the same
magnet right here and what's the other
thing this is just random tasks oh i see
so that's the test if it breaks free
from this task
and this goes over here and you've seen
it in action for example like [ __ ]
like let's say i'm designing a new
bartle brigade shirt
right and then i'm going and then like
we're supposed to by the end of today
and design four shirts
but then i end up getting caught up in
[ __ ] ink colors or [ __ ] the
material of the shirt and then i started
going down research i'm like oh [ __ ]
when was the [ __ ] polyester invented
and i start going in and because i'm
getting [ __ ] sucked in i'm glued into
this thing and then now i can tell you
like how how this the sandstone gray how
it came to be and all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
right and then you're like bart where's
the four shirts i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't
have any shirts made yet
cuz i [ __ ] detach from that and
they're like
and i'm stuck there got it so that's
what because of that and i know how
[ __ ] uh um how much of a time suck it
can be i like as soon as i feel it guys
get back in there you know before right
so i'll go oh look you got to cut your
nails i'm like oh i sure do got to cut
my nails and get a haircut and get a
facial hey you know something [ __ ]
get your ass back in there you don't got
time for that [ __ ] yeah got it
because then you'll probably buy the
best [ __ ] clippers out there for your
nails yep and then you're gonna be like
did you know that vegas has the number
one [ __ ] nail salon of whatever he'll
be like what the [ __ ] okay i get it yeah
you do do that or even if like let's say
i'm working or something or doing
something you go you know can you just
go cut your nails in the shower you're
gonna take a shower anyways i might end
up being a shower for two hours because
then i'm like well i might as well
[ __ ] luffa pumice stone this yeah
pumice stone please and then i'm gonna
be like okay cool now that i uh
now that i'm like you know using a
scrubber i'm going this way i should
probably do against the grain too so go
like this and then i'll probably
how does that feel i'll probably go this
way and so now it'll take me like
if it takes someone i don't know 10
minutes to scrub their body it might
take me an hour because i'm not just i'm
not gonna do a [ __ ] job like how
regular people do it yeah me me me i'm
gonna do it like a regular person might
go like this then i'm like well that
does do nothing so i gotta do it like in
a very orderly fashion and then we all
know that the knee uh skin is also much
thicker yeah yeah so if i went one two
three four five the knee needs at least
15 or 20 strokes so one two three four
five six seven eight like i can get down
into the [ __ ] nitty gritty like if i
let ocd take over it's [ __ ] crazy
you know what i mean like even if i
brush my hair how do you keep it at bay
how do you slap it what are the slapping
like as soon as i feel that [ __ ] just
slap it
slap it back in place obviously you're
not slapping it but what are you saying
like what are you just like nope you
[ __ ] dumb ass let's go this way yeah
i see so it's kind of like a food
craving when you're on a diet yeah you
gotta the all the self-doubt yeah
because you're like oh yeah i mean just
a little bit no [ __ ] let's move away
yeah like even every daily when i brush
my teeth
that's why i like to count because it
removes the other excess shears go one
two three four five i want to do if i
want to divide whatever right but if i
don't i'm like well if the molars are in
the back oh no the molars need extra
attention from the front because the
front is always constantly getting
abrasion and then and i'm like okay cool
then i should probably and the molar has
three sides so i gotta hit the top this
side like i'll [ __ ] get 30 minutes
there's times when i was when i was at
home as an only child where i literally
brushed my teeth for an hour
when i was just at home because i had
nothing else to do so i just get caught
up i'm just [ __ ] doing that for an
entire hour
did you ever see this behavior
i don't know i don't know if she did
damn you should ask her
man you guys don't talk at all nah
there's times where i've taken like 12
showers at home too
because like i'm just like i'm like
washing and i come out and i'm like
well that's not really scrubbing
so i go back in and like scrub
and then i'm like well i just scrubbed
oh i forgot the lotion
and i'm like well now my it's not that
supple shower skin so i better go back
in and shower so i shower
and then okay now i put the lotion on
you know and then i start to sweat
because i'm moving so much i'm like well
[ __ ] that ruined the shower didn't it so
i'm going to take another shower
until i get every single step right
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and that and yeah
because of that i i i can get carried
away so [ __ ] easy i gotta like
get your ass back in lane
yeah [ __ ] let the nails grow dude
yeah i don't think i've ever seen that
behavior like my personality i mean i
have but like to the success my
personality type is probably the
[ __ ] that build ships and
bottles
that's probably like what i should be
[ __ ] doing
like look at those those kind of you
know what the [ __ ] monocle
monocle
whatever the [ __ ] they have
a little microscope yeah that's like a
[ __ ] telescope yeah i don't know what
the [ __ ] what kind of scope maybe
monoscope i don't know
a [ __ ] monoscope yeah those two adhd
and ocd together
it's uh it's a it's a horrible
combination because they're actually
like opposite sides of the spectrum like
ones i can't focus and one that's i
focus too hard because that's the
compulsive part right where you have to
do it you have to do it you have to do
it so it's like that's why it feels like
a magnet really i have to i have to i
have to i have to and then so like once
i
am on there then i'm [ __ ] like hey
[ __ ] it
right and then above my adhd kicks in
then i'm like oh
what's that oh [ __ ]
look at that so if i can hate [ __ ] the
things that are productive then i just
stay glued to it
damn
yeah
i'm so exhausted listening to this maybe
that's why i sleep early
maybe i'm exhausted maybe that's why
it's like 10 o'clock i'm like
oh [ __ ] you've been hate [ __ ]
everything hey [ __ ] all [ __ ] day
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] tiring
damn
do you want to know what mine is like
trying to figure out polka dot or
stripes are the best nah it's not even
like that i mean for sure i live with
high anxiety so i'm always thinking of a
million things all the goddamn time
until it gets done yeah so i'm like it's
like a ruminating thought over and over
and over and over and over but it's
never to the point where i'm like
okay like it like consumes me oh or
maybe it does but like no i just got
used to it but um
yeah i don't have anything like that
like before um i mean i pretty much pee
before i eat but if i don't pee before i
eat the whole meal is like oh [ __ ] it
just feels crazy the whole [ __ ] meal
what does it feel like like it's just
really uneasy i'm like oh she's gonna go
[ __ ] a pee dude what the [ __ ] how can i
even though i know i don't need to pee
because i just peed or something but i
didn't but i didn't produ i didn't go
through that ritual
what if you just keep it like that
like for like a week and just like live
with that feeling i've done it and uh
and honestly the most beneficial thing
to i think all of this weird [ __ ]
behavior was boot camp
because like you don't have a choice you
don't have a choice and it's survival
you're [ __ ] starving you're hungry so
i think like ocd plus adhd with like
first world like really nice living and
it's easy to give into those things
right
but if you're already don't have time to
pee or people are [ __ ] [ __ ] and
pissing in their pants because they
already don't have [ __ ] time
um then a lot of it doesn't really even
[ __ ]
matter i'll still get the urge but
because you're getting like punched in
your face or like there's like crazy
hard [ __ ] happening like when you're
running out of breath trying to climb up
a
10 mile mountain some of those things
that's kind of falls by the wayside
because when it's
time for survivability your brain will
re-prioritize things so a lot of that
really helped me out like crazy but
even on that note i was the [ __ ]
recruit that got yelled at in the
[ __ ] shower in first phase
what is that what the [ __ ] does that
mean
so first phase is the first phase of
boot camp it's the first how many phases
are there three phases in the marine
corps boot camp so you have first phase
which is at mcrd which is marine corps
recruit depot in san diego second phase
you go to camp pendleton where you do
all the shooting and all the mountain
warfare type [ __ ]
in first phase
because i was still like assimilating i
was still trying to get used to ocd
we're not taking showers right like the
the we have shower games but we don't
take showers so shower games is like we
come back from [ __ ] training it's
like 10 o'clock at night everyone got
[ __ ] dirt [ __ ] camel pain all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's 80 of us
there's only like 10 showers but
everyone get the [ __ ] in the shower
right now so you're running turn on the
hot water right now you turn on and then
put soap on you right now oh get the
[ __ ] out of the shower so you're
literally in the shower for 30 minutes
oh you want to move slow get the [ __ ]
back
30 seconds yeah 30 seconds get the [ __ ]
back in the shower turn the water hot
cold and you have clothes on
so you're just rubbing soap over your
clothes so you have soap studs dirt
whatever get the [ __ ] out of my head
right now and you're going to sleep so
you're you go to sleep all [ __ ] up you
still have mud you're all wet you're wet
your shit's all [ __ ] up right like
like yeah like wet mud dirt soap camo
because you just really want to shake up
your life
sometimes you're running into the
[ __ ] shower with boots on
and then you're sleeping they just
really want to show you anything can be
done whatever comforts you thought out
the window
i'm the [ __ ] when it's lights
out
i'm there
everyone's probably exhausted from a
whole day of training like
everyone's snoring but my [ __ ] ocd is
like and i wait for everyone to sleep
and then i get up
and i bring my soap
and my like uh my washcloth
and i go in there so i would rather i'm
exhausted right we went to sleep
probably like 11 or 12. we're gonna wake
up at 4am
every morning lights up lights lights
lights lights
i would rather waste my sleep
to still shower for that extra 30
minutes by myself in my personal time
and i was a [ __ ] that was there
one night when a drill instructor walks
by at midnight and he goes
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing this
recruit's taking a shower sir because
you're taking a [ __ ] shower you're
taking a [ __ ] shower i'm like yes sir
let's get the [ __ ] out of my head right
now
and then uh but i was still the
[ __ ] that took a shower did it
because that's how strong the the it is
that i was like i can't go to sleep not
clean
you're a [ __ ] i'm just kidding
no it sounds like it's a [ __ ]
nightmare ma'am i'm sure there's
positive [ __ ] to it though
i think when i'm like
lock on to anything i can hate [ __ ]
everything to lock on yeah yeah yeah
yeah you have crazy focus yeah so i
think if i get focused and i get sucked
into something um i think that's why i
learn really fast about things i can get
really immersed into a world
and uh
and that's the really productive side of
it
damn
i always learn something new
yeah
that is [ __ ] nutsos i mean that's
pretty rad though like you've been able
to like figure out like what it is
um
like what's the good the bad and then
how to make it work for yourself it only
took you 38 years
yeah i mean
so i just realized i [ __ ] the nails
and i get it the lobe one like in the
list of priorities yeah [ __ ] it it ain't
that up there
it's not that important i guess
i'm sorry for bringing it up i'll never
bring it up again i pretty much my
signal to cut my nails is when the nails
start getting bent forward when i'm
wearing shoes and i heard something uh
fine i have to cut it now it's not an
aesthetic thing please let's not go back
there that just [ __ ] hurts my [ __ ]
body it actually hurts
okay
on that note let's wrap it up let's wrap
it up
yeah that's it i'm done i'm outta here
thank you so much for listening
see you guys next time okay bye